mais d'abord le récit de ce que l'on
croyait être le dernier conseil des
ministres du gouvernement castex qui
aura droit finalement à une semaine de
rab civile de l'être
une photo souvenir comme pour
immortaliser le premier est possible
dernier conseil des ministres après la
victoire d'emmanuel macron mais les
ministres eux mêmes s'y sont trompés et
ont fait marche arrière il semble bien
que le gouvernement castex se retrouvera
une fois de plus la semaine prochaine
le conseil des ministres de la semaine
prochaine là je crois pas encore été
convoqué mais je crois que j'ai été
assez clair avec vous sur le fait que je
ne vous ai pas annoncer ici qu'il
s'agissait du dernier conseil des
ministres ce conseil des ministres a été
l'occasion de revenir sur le score d
emmanuel macron au second tour moins
élevés qu'il ya cinq ans un score qui
impose de nouvelles méthodes nous
entendrons tous les messages du genre
nous répondrons aux colères et aux
inquiétudes des français ne relèveront
les défis qui se dressent devant nous le
quinquennat qui s'ouvre sera collectif
pour les français auprès des français
avec eux un changement sur la forme et
le fond mais avec quelle équipe si
emmanuel macron prend son temps il a
dressé hier lors de son déplacement à
cergy un portrait robot du futur
locataire de matignon
dépassement la couleur politique ne dit
pas tout je mènerai quelqu'un
est attaché à la question sociale et à
la question environnementale la question
productif un portrait qui pourrait
correspondre à elisabeth bornes femme de
gauche elle a conduit avec succès les
réformes de l'apprentissage et de
l'assurance chômage d'autres noms
circulent parmi les membres du
gouvernement comme julien de normandie
mais il pourrait aussi s'agir d'une
personnalité extérieure en attendant
jean castex devraient jouer les
prolongations au moins jusqu'au milieu
de la semaine prochaine s'il n'existe
aucune règle le premier ministre avait
confirmé qu'il suivrait la tradition et
démissionnerait quelques jours après
l'élection présidentielle
voilà l'actualité politique de cette
journée marquée par
le fait que le président finalement a
décidé de prendre son temps le débat
tout de suite avec mes invités nathalie
segaunes bonsoir et bienvenue vous êtes
journaliste à l'opinion bérengère
bonbons soir bien aussi journaliste
essayiste auteur de cette biographie
d'edouard philippe le ciu qui est publié
aux éditions de l'archipel
j'accueille également benjamin morel
bonsoir bienvenue aux de vous retrouver
au maître de conférences en droit public
à l'université paris ii panthéon assas
et métis accrue pas savoir éditorialiste
politique bienvenue à vous aussi
nathalie secondes comment vous expliquez
ce petit petite surprise pas non plus un
fait majeur dans l'histoire politique de
la 5ème république mais le fait que mm
macro et d'essayer de prendre son temps
c'est une constante chez emmanuel macron
on a quand même observé dans premier
quinquennat que il a chaque fois il
prend son temps
il met du temps je pense qu'il l'est
son entourage dit souvent qu'il a pas
tout à fait les qualités d'un drh d'un
bon drh il a du mal à choisir du mal à
trouver les personnes
donc souvenez-vous pour remplacer gérard
collomb
il a quand même mis quinze jours et je
dois refaire dit en
mettant edouard philippe à la place donc
là
voilà ils essaient il fait du maquereau
je pense que ça l'amusait aussi un peu
de mettre tout le monde le supplice
chinois pour pour les ministres je pense
qu'il doit il prendre un certain plaisir
pour les journalistes aussi il aime pas
il aime montrer qu'il est le maître des
horloges comme comme on dit autour de
lui donc c'est ça correspond à sa
personnalité après il ya une équation
politique extrêmement complexe à
résoudre sur ce poste de premier
ministre puisqu'il a lui-même annoncé
qu'ils seraient chargées de la
transition écologique
donc il faut qu'il faut qu'il donne et
de ce côté là il ya la bataille des
législatives à mener donc c'est sans
doute lui qui l'amènera en premier mais
enfin il faut quand même quelqu'un qui
donne une impulsion derrière parce que
quitte à changer jean castex qui est
excellent sous tous rapports dont on
nous a dit qu'il était parfait et qu'il
était le premier nice parfait autant
mettre quelqu'un qui a un poids
politique enfin kiki qui a pu quand même
mener le combat balla qui aussi même
quand même le combat donc c'est
compliqué et je pense qu'on a on
attendra encore longtemps derrière pour
le gouvernement au complet et on est
loin du compte on annonçait un premier
gouvernement resserré bérenger rebonds
moi j'ai deux depuis que j'ai appris
cette mais je me suis mis un peu à la
place des ministres c'est quand même
c'est quand même le jeu c'est pas le
supplice chinois la de la goutte d'eau
face et il avait déjà fait les cartons
étaient patents qui regarde ça c'est
assez classique mais ils ont su le mail
hier voici comment on quitte le cabinet
marche à suivre archivage vous détruisez
ça vous gardez ça ce qui met notre
mosphere un peu particulière bon même si
tout le monde s'y attend après il prend
son temps mais imaginez ce qu'on dirait
si si le gouvernement était déjà prêt et
il y aurait un dieu sait qu'on a on a
souligné à quel point où certains ont
accusé d'avoir voulu en jambes et
l'élection 6 il dégainait tout de suite
comme ça son nouveau gouvernement ça
pourrait voir aussi mauvais genre là il
prend le temps d'entendre le résultat et
de de réfléchir et puis deux et puis de
recueillir les réponses éventuelle des
personnes qui sollicitent parce qu'après
tout
l'équation est complexe pour lui mais
l'équation est complexe pour les verts
éventuellement qu'ils essaient de
d'emmener dans son dans son escarcelle
la gauche la droite enfin là c'est
compliqué pour tous oui puis au rythme
des mots on y reviendra sur le nom du
premier ministre mais il ya il ya des
noms qui sort des démentis bref c'est
quand même un jeu un peu particulier
benjamin morel il ne le fera pas mais il
pourrait renommer le même gouvernement à
ryad n'empêche dans la constitution
pourrait tout à fait d'ailleurs jean
castex n'est pas obligé de présenter sa
démission c'est à dire que
constitutionnellement il pourrait
potentiellement rester après vous avez
trois ans je pense c'est à dire qu'il ya
un enjeu d'arrière-ban en effet où on
sait qu emmanuel macron a toujours du
mal à trouver des personnalités qui
pourraient convenir à lui-même et à son
gouvernement on parlait tout à l'heure
du remplacement de gérard collomb
l'autre aspect c'est que on sait pas
exactement comment vont se jouer ces
législatives c'est pas du tout la même
chose si on a des élections législatives
qui se font et bien un peu je dirais de
manière confidentielle et si on n'a pas
de vraie campagne si on a une
dépolitisation d'élections et un fort
taux d'abstention se dire que
l'électorat de centre-droit va être
primordial c'est au contraire on a une
initiative très politisée c'est pas tout
à fait le même profil de campagnes voyez
donc ce n'est peut-être pas tout à fait
le même profil de premier ministre et à
ce stade là bien malin ce oui c'est ça
c'est ce que j'ai à vous dire à dire
lesquelles ces deux cas de figure pour
l'instant c'est par essence et parleront
législatives je reste très dubitatif on
n'a pas encore vraiment sinon c'est que
la gauche essaie de mobiliser la droite
et plus en difficulté et auraient plus
intérêt à une élection plutôt local je
dirais donc pour l'instant simplement
trop tôt pour le dire et le troisième
élément est bien c'est que entre les
présidentielles et législatives
on les dit souvent vous avez un temps de
latence important et donc à partir de là
les faits dessous de la présidentielle
n'aura pas lieu si vous nommer un
nouveau gouvernement si vous avez un
effet wow avec quelques ministres ça
peut malgré tout compter et ça peut
permettre de redynamiser faut pas
oublier que le premier mandat d'
emmanuel macron n'est pas encore
terminée et se termine le 13 mai
jusqu'au 13 mai on est encore lors du
premier mandat on ne passera au second
que le 14 mai qu'est ce qu'ils font dans
les ministères plus rien à faire courant
de ce qu'est ce qui va se passer
mercredi prochain conseil des ministres
restera ne s'est pas un texte une loi
alors dû
oui vous savez comme moi que la fin il
ya il ya l'expédition des affaires
courantes exactement mais le parlement
ne siège plus en version les chétive
actuellement il pourrait en revanche on
pourrait très bien imaginer qu'il soit
reconvoquer entre maintenant les
législatives mais pour l'instant on est
en effet dans l'expédition des affaires
courantes emmanuel macron qui est la
cible préférée n'est des insoumis de
jean luc mélenchon la preuve avec ce
dérapage signé françois ruffin député de
la somme c'était ce matin sur france
inter
aujourd'hui un drapeau de la gauche qui
est au qui peut briller alors qu'il
pourrait ne plus elle pourrait ne plus
exister quand on a eu cinq ans de
hollande et que son héritier son fils
bâtard et emmanuel macron est présentée
comme étant la continuité de cette
gauche tout ça pour être laminés dans le
pays ça ne l'est pas
laetitia c'est un dérapage mais il est
parfaitement contrôlée évidemment vous
avez bien vu que il scande sa phrase
jusqu'à ce mot qu'il a préparée en amont
qu'il a peut-être déjà utilisé parce que
il est il et il a l'habitude justement
d'utiliser un vocabulaire très dur il
s'est imposé comme le principal opposant
emmanuel macron quand emmanuel macron
est arrivé à l'elysée sauf que sauf que
il est toujours dans l'ombre de jean luc
mélenchon qui n'a pas voulu céder sa
place mais c'est vrai que françois
ruffin tout de suite on peut vraiment
retracer son opposition emmanuel macron
il avait aussi écrit un livre oui le
tutoyaient il fallait voir les
qualificatifs qui l'employait contre
pour qualifier emmanuel macron donc moi
ça ne m'a pas vraiment surprise si vous
voulez parce que encore une fois ça
appartient au vocabulaire de françois
richard dent encore une fois la mise en
scène de son opposition à emmanuel
macron qui je vous le rappelle est son
ancien copain de lycée et donc il y a
une histoire commune entre stand ces
deux hommes qui datent de l'adolescence
et qui aujourd'hui fini à mon avis est
vraiment dans une mise en scène qui est
un tout petit peu trop caricatural
nathalie segaunes choquant quand vous
entendez cette phrase bouzid bon après
tout une parmi d'autres au contraire
c'est révélateur quand même alors je
vous cache pas que j'ai entendu ce matin
que j'ai pas à sursauter parce que ça
fait partie un peu de son style
rufin après il faut le remettre dans le
contexte est la fille ils ont une
bataille à mener là qui est qui qui vont
mener très fortement on l'a vu déjà
quand mélenchon reprend bruno le maire
sur l'histoire du 49-3 très violemment
en point que le maire est obligé de
reculer ils ont une bataille anomique
mené qui est celle d'être la principale
force d'opposition à l'assemblée au
minimum si ce n'est remporter ma fille
d'employer des mots comme cela c'est pas
lisse de bata
après il faut se poser la question de la
responsabilité des personnalités
publiques quand ça quand ça diffuse
quand ça infuse dans l'opinion publique
en quelle année dans la radicalité ya
plus limites après
emmanuel macron il parle d'emmerder les
français
une génération de politiques qui
franchit certaine
certains une certaine barrière du
langage qui est passé dans un langage
beaucoup plus familier
mais je pense que cette bataille enfin
le ton de cette campagne ils ont intérêt
les filles à rester à garder leur
électorat mobilisés jusqu'en juin ça va
être très dur donc plus ça ira plus ils
taperont fort et plus ils sont violents
à l'égard des manuels mac contre moi j'y
interprète dans campagne forcément dur
peut-être violente à venir benjamin
morel il faut politiser c'est à dire que
normalement qu'est ce qui se passe on
dit souvent lors des élections
législatives le les français veulent
donner une majorité au président la
république c'est pas vrai en fait ce qui
se passe lors des législatives post
présidentielle c'est que l'électorat de
la majorité est mobilisé il y croit et
donc il va voter l'électorat de
l'opposition lui se démobilisent si vous
voulez l'emporter vous devez mobiliser
cet électorat et vous avez deux mois
pour le faire évidemment si cet
électorat commence à rentrer dans une
forme d'apathie si jamais il entend plus
parler de la politique ou qu'ils ne
voient plus de politique et bien ce
moment là il ne viendra pas voté et
l'électorat la fillette un électorat
relativement abstentionnistes en tout
cas beaucoup plus abstentionnistes que
l'électorat de la république en marche
donc il faut cliver et il faut cliver
sur les thèmes de la vie pour arriver à
bobby cette base électorale on peut
penser ce qu'on veut ensuite de la forme
et cetera mais du point de vue purement
politique du point de vue purement
électorales c'est pas idiot
bérengère bonté les députés fils est
assez intéressant parce que dans
plusieurs interviews
radio ou télé on leur pose la question
de l'éventualité d'une défaite aux
législatives même si voilages en
revanche on se voit premier ministre il
se projette déjà dans la presse dans la
défaite est dans le fait de combattre
dans la rue les futures réformes de des
macros et notamment la réforme des
retraites est ce que c'est quand même
pas un peu particulier juste après un
scrutin près c'est comme si la
présentielle servait à rien voyez ce que
je veux dire en quelque sorte oui alors
il ya une on élu un président est élu on
peut considérer comme normal qu'ils
appliqueront qu'il applique son
programme mais yahia cerises ont ils ont
en ligne de mire ce 3e tour depuis le
début
les mélenchonistes et et le la
particularité de ce deuxième tour macro
le pen si c'est déjà la deuxième fois et
mais même la troisième si on considère
2002 fait que pour eux effectivement
c'est un deuxième tour qui ne compte pas
qui n'a pas la même valeur
après il se il se voit déjà dans la rue
et imaginant aussi ce que c'est une
forme de lucidité aussi de se dire que
tout ça n'est que le fameux mélenchon à
matignon ne n'aura pas lieu généreux
d'une certaine façon c'est ça que ça
veut dire aussi c'est que c'est que leur
place sera dans la rue pour lequel je
vais un peu de nuance et thomas ce
qu'est ce que vous dites parce que
dimanche soir il y avait sur le plateau
de l'émission dans lequel j'ai participé
julien odoul donc est reine et il y
avait aussi une représentante d europe
ecologie les verts la france insoumise
ils avaient tous ce discours c'est à
dire que tous ils ont tenté
d'instrumentaliser cette colère que
ne fais autrement tout le monde certes
toute l'opposition et s'était même
choquant c'est à dire qu'on leur a quand
même rétorqué que là il y avait voilà un
risque oui d'embrasement et qu'il y
aurait une responsabilité des des red et
de l'opposition ça leur semblait pas
vraiment valable comme argument après
tout et vous avez raison je pense que on
en est là c'est à dire que dans les mots
oui c'est violent moi je préfère
honnêtement que ça reste dans les mots
que là c'est carrément un appel à
descendre dans la rue il a appelé tous
les français mécontents ceux qui n'ont
pas voté pour emmanuel macron à venir
manifester alors leur colère c'est
dangereux alors je ne pense pas que ce
soit la réforme la plus attendue par nos
concitoyens et qu'elle est forcément un
effet apaisant mais benjamin morel est
ce que emmanuel macron doit rapidement
mettre en place la cette commission
transpartisane pour réformer nos
institutions est ce que c'est un message
qui peut être important la danse est
avant avant législatives alors si jamais
il ya deux éléments pour réformer les
institutions le mode de scrutin ça peut
passer par une loi ordinaire on pourrait
imaginer la proportionnelle relativement
rapidement évidemment ce serait se tirer
une balle dans le pied avant les
prochaines législatives
juridiquement c'est possible avant avant
le 12 juin sa peau ce qui est possible
il vous faut vous convoquer le parlement
acceptera il n'y a pas on dit beaucoup
il faut que ce soit réformée un an au
moins avant ces conventionnel il n'ya
pas il ya aucune contrainte
constitutionnelle emploi le faire mais
évidemment ce serait se tirer une balle
dans le pied pour emmanuel macron il
préfère laisser ce cadeau-là edouard
philippe fois son successeur donc on
aura peut-être de la proportionnelle
mais en 2027 ensuite le reste nécessite
une révision constitutionnelle donc
l'aval du sénat allait mettre d'accord
la majorité de droite sénatoriale et les
revendications de la fille et du
rassemblement national
bon courage évidemment c'est à dire que
pour le coup il peut y avoir une
commission mais cette commission
enfantera difficilement quelque chose de
consensuel entre les oppositions elle
même donc il y aura probablement quelque
chose qui sera lancée il faut pas lui
donner non plus trop d'importance
évidemment je plaide un peu contre ma
paroisse parce que je
constitutionnaliste mais quand vous
prenez un sondage il faut qu'en février
2020 en pleine crise des gilet jaune sur
les priorités des français les questions
institutionnelles en en plein débat sur
le risque sont une priorité pour 6 % des
français donc on ne sort pas d'une
avancée par les intentions même si
évidemment c'est important avec
peut-être j'ai lu ça dans l'aube c'est
un françois hollande qui pourrait être
nommé en tout cas ça aurait été proposé
par emmanuel macron à françois hollande
de diriger cette commission
transpartisane il a refusé de répondre
ce matin oui oui à cette question mais
effectivement alors on va prendre un peu
de temps pour se concentrer sur le nom
et la personnalité du premier ministre
on l'a un peu évoqué avec vous nathalie
secondes laetitia vous avez tenté à
partir des déclarations publiques 1
faites par les uns et les autres de
dresser une sorte de portrait robot et
en premier lieu à des manuels macron
parce que c'est lui qui s'amusent à
jouer un peu avec les journalistes les
médias qui sont très excités avec ce
feuilleton acquis pour succéder à jean
castex je vous invite juste à regarder
les jt je vous assure il y avait une
petite musique comme ça qui faisait
monter le suspense on se serait cru dans
une série netflix donc le président bah
il a donné le premier indice a déjà
entre les deux tours à son meeting à
marseille écoutez
pour placer l'écologie au coeur du
nouveau paradigme politique
comme au 19ème siècle
ou face aux défis éducatifs
jules ferry
était à la fois président du conseil et
ministre de l'instruction publique
mon prochain premier ministre
sera directement chargé de la
planification écologique la
[Applaudissements]
planification écologique c'est un terme
de jean luc mélenchon je doute que ce
soit quand même voilà la priorité pour
emmanuel macron balorre premiers indices
il sera où elle sera écolo et pourquoi
je vous dit elle parce que lundi matin
clément ball secrétaire d'état aux
affaires européennes donne un deuxième
indice
le prénom est l'occasion de s'exprimer
il aurait le souhait d'avoir évidemment
une nomination féminine à matignon voilà
donc on résume un écolo une femme écolo
on va s'arrêter là et bien non puisque
on l'a passée dans le sujet mais alors
vraiment c'est tellement
compliqué à comprendre que personne ne
l'a retenu mme emmanuel macron hier en
déplacement à cergy redonne un troisième
indice sur ce futur cette future
première premier ministre
pense qu'on n'a pas le sombre dans la
voix il y à la clé il est il est dit il
dit il sera attaché à la question
sociale environnementale et productive
ça arrive mais laissons parts et son
papa désolé donc l'important c'est qu'on
a compris ce qu'il est ce qu'il ramène
chez à la question sociale
environnementale et producteurs alors là
oui il rajoutait productif s'est pas
totalement neutre ça veut dire quoi
peut-être pas jusqu'à la décroissance
d'une partie de l'usiné sans quelqu'un a
compris c'est mieux que moi mais il me
semble que ça donne un indice sur non à
une personnalité qui sera en faveur de
la décroissance mais tout ce qu'on sait
c'est que emmanuel macron hésitez vous
avez tout à fait raison et des sites il
prend quand même quelques conseils on
sait que in fine et c'est toujours lui
qui décide tout seul et vous l'avez dit
aussi benjamin morel il a jusqu'au 13
mai puisque son mandat jusqu'au 13 mai
alors les sources bien informées parle
du 8 mai voilà pour notamment bruno
jeudy je vais citer dans paris match du
8 mai pour la nomination du successeur
ou de celle qui succèdera à ce que je ne
sais pas comment le dire au féminin à
jean castex bérengère bon que le
troisième premier ministre emmanuel
macron ça doit être plutôt un technicien
façon castex un politique façon philippe
ton à trois pattes avec toutes les
qualités pour il a tellement dit qu'une
femme se serait quand même il y songeait
déjà en 2017 il faut se souvenir que
très vite le le principal client
candidat c'était dans l'esprit des
manuels macron c'est edouard philippe
may mais le nom de nathalie kosciusko
morizet avait déjà traversé son esprit
on avait même parlé valérie pécresse a
failli avait il tenait a été chercher
une femme a trouvé ne remplissait pas
tous les critères mais donc je pense une
femme cette histoire de d'environnement
évidemment et centrale il en parle
depuis marseille il en parle le résultat
le lien site mais du coup si on veut
faire femme écolo on arrive quand même
un choix qui se réduit on a beau moi
c'est drôle ça fait des mois que je les
imagine comme ça pardon mais dans mon
salon que si j'étais né macro j'irai
chercher les nathalie kosciusko morizet
qui a cette légitimité qui a été
ministre de l'écologie de nicolas
sarkozy elle a dit clairement sur rtl ce
matin que c'était non après ceux qui
disent non dans un premier temps sont
pas forcément complètement de la vie
politique c'est les antilles la vie
politique mais elle a hélas d'autres
handicaps et là je pense que c'est un
caractère un petit peu un petit peu oui
son image écornée le trompait avec avec
manuel en cours ça peut être compliqué
on a parlé aussi beaucoup de carole
delga là pour le coup ça ça règle
d'autres la présidente de la région la
réussite annie on est à gauche je pense
que ce serait un drôle de choix de sa
part à elle elle a démenti voit la super
maman et tout ça est compliqué et du cou
je pense que ce critère environnemental
et ils sont prêts centrale ou non
certes elle a été ministre en charge des
dossiers parlez-en aux ong paralysant
aux différents acteurs environnementaux
ils sont pas convaincus par la fibre
environnementale de l'examen des bandes
et quant aux verts je ne vois pas qui
parmi les verts après les expériences
hulot duflot et autres auraient envie
d'aller semaine dans cette galère il y
anime jadot a démenti lui aussi il fut
enlevé par des éléments cités oui parce
qu'il n'avait pas été très clair l'autre
matin sur france inter il essaie quand
même la porte ouverte moi je pense qu'il
il aura quand même envie de surprendre
c'est pour ça que le nom d'elisabeth
bornes
pareil convient pas du tout c'est à dire
qu'il va vouloir afficher une prise de
guerre à mon avis quelqu'un qui vienne
la société civile certainement room ou
de la gauchère moi je peins prise de
guerre à gauche il est prise de guerre à
droite il ya déjà eu beaucoup voilà une
prise alors il ya tout un il a tout un
entourage quand même qui le poussent
beaucoup à prendre quelqu'un qui vient
de la gauche pour rééquilibrer par
rapport à ce qui s'est passé dans le
premier quinquennat parce que parce
qu'ils ont peur législatif de se faire
piquer des circonscriptions par la
gauche et il ya quelqu'un que emmanuel
macron essaie de convaincre depuis
très longtemps de
depuis le début du quinquennat qui n'est
pas parvenu pour l'instant attiré dans
ses filets c'est valérie rabault il est
très
très convaincu de ses qualités de sa
compétence c'est quelqu'un de très
sérieux de très solides sur le fond
populaire elle est pas du tout
populaires mais franchement ça fait un
signe de ralliement était pas voilà lé
pa lé pas connu non plus pas plus que
l'été edouard philippe en 2017 voilà je
pense qu'il va chercher à faire un coup
dans ce style là je ne vois pas du tout
prendre un de ses ministres actuels ou
ou
quelqu'un de très connu alors benjamin
morel c'est un nouveau binôme exécutif
qui va voilà qui qu'on va pouvoir
commenter quand ils feront le creux des
trains mais ce qui est intéressant c'est
que l'équilibré de ce binôme il a quand
même été transformé depuis le passage au
quinquennat c'est c'est si on compare
les binômes
du des mandats de valéry giscard
d'estaing françois mitterrand ou même
jacques chirac à ceux de nicolas sarkozy
françois hollande est là emmanuel macron
c'est plus du tout le même équilibre il
a été profondément transformé parce
qu'en réalité c'est toute l'alchimie de
la vème république qui a été transformé
l'alchimie entre au moins trois poles
président premier mist majorité
parlementaire et parti politique
majoritaire et aujourd'hui vous avez des
partis qui sont déliquescent dans la
république en marche est imparti au sens
juridique ou sociologique ce n'est pas
quelque chose qui vous a pris à la
sortie du lycée qui nous a formés dans
une tradition politique et cetera la
majorité parlementaire a été à la fois
très je tairai très disciplinée et très
déstructuré et donc on n'a plus du tout
la même situation est donc à partir de
là le rôle du premier ministre n'est pas
tout à fait de même et malgré tout son
rôle il va devoir être important lors du
prochain quinquennat parce que si on a
une majorité parlementaire il ya une
possibilité vous voyez on va y revenir
mais toutes les difficultés aujourd'hui
à traiter avec horizons pour la majorité
il ya une possibilité que cette majorité
très rapidement et bien soit une
majorité qui se déstructure et le
président de la république ne peut pas
être au parlement soit falot réunir en
congrès etc article 18 il peut pas être
au parlement il peut pas maîtriser
directement sa majorité il a besoin d'un
ministre et d'un chef de gouvernement
qui malgré tout joue ce rôle là et donc
ce faisant il va falloir un ministre tu
peux pas vous donner de noms je veux
d'abord les deux derniers je les avais
pas du tout vu venir les par ailleurs
c'est pas c'est pas là où je suis le
meilleur mais dans la divination mais
malgré tout vous avez plusieurs
nécessité pour lui il faut que vous ayez
un ministre à ses politiques pour tenir
une majorité et vous il faut que vous
ayez un ministre peut-être de gauche
mais qui tient malgré tout la base
électorale la base électorale
aujourd'hui de la république en marche
elle demeure quand même où deux tiers à
droite et cette base électorale si
notamment les élections conduisent à une
forte abstention
et bien c'est une base électorale qu'on
a retrouvés aux municipales aux
départementales ou régionales et à ce
moment là elle a voté quoi elle a voté l
air est en train députés qui va être un
député pas du tout implanté venant de la
reine parce qu'en fait fin du cumul des
mandats et caetera et améliorer ce
secteur à qui elle s est implantée
depuis des années il n'y à risque que
malgré tout dans des élections ultra
locales et bien l'absence de vraie
campagne nationale joue contre la
majorité donc malgré tout il faut un
politique qui parle au moins un peu à
l'électorat de centre-droit alors
justement vous évoquer la question du
parti d'edouard philippe le parti
horizon alexandre pousse à vous pouvez
nous rejoindre sur ce plateau bonsoir à
les 110 a manifestement un peu de
friture sur la ligne entre la république
en marche et horizons mais effectivement
alors thomas pour bien comprendre on va
d'abord rappeler quels sont les
objectifs d'edouard philippe et de son
nouveau parti horizon dans cette
campagne des élections législatives
premier objectif est bien investir au
moins cinquante candidats dans ces
élections des candidats dans 50
circonscriptions c'est le seuil pour
obtenir les subventions de l'état aux
partis politiques et ça c'est très
important pour horizon le second
objectif d'edouard philippe c'est de
créer un groupe politique au raison à l'
horizon à l'assemblée nationale et pour
cela il faut avoir au moins quinze
députés alors ce sont des objectifs
largement atteignable pour ce parti mais
le problème c'est qu'au horizon qui
appartient la majorité présidentielle
est bien pour l'instant ils sont exclus
des discussions autour d' emmanuel
macron sur la campagne des législatives
par exemple cette semaine le parti s'est
dit je cite surpris de ne pas avoir été
convié une arrivée à l'elysée sur les
futurs candidats qui vont être investis
par la majorité présidentielle et du
côté des responsables politiques qui ont
rejoint horizons eh bien on estime que
ce parti doit avoir sa place autour de
la table notamment pour convaincre les
électeurs de droite dans cette campagne
on va écouter frédéric valletoux le
maire horizon de fontainebleau sur les
images de samia de chair crois que c'est
l'intérêt du présent la république et
dans marche de bien comprendre que
horizon c'est une jambe droite qui est
solide qui est loyal et qui est solide
et que on a vu le vote des français la
france est quand même très à droite et
l'électorat de droite fidèles à emmanuel
macron et bien il doit se retrouver au
moment des législatives alors quand on
regarde la répartition actuelle des
sièges de l'assemblée nationale eh bien
on comprend qu'il ya une difficulté pour
edouard philippe c'est que la majorité
actuelle présidentielles et bien elle
est pléthorique avec près de 350 députés
si on compte la république en marche le
modem agir et les députés sortants qui
veulent se représenter et bien ils vont
être naturellement investi donc
l'objectif pour horizon et pour edouard
philippe c'est d'aller chercher les
sièges des républicains ils en ont
actuellement une centaine et on sait que
le party les républicains est
actuellement très affaibli après le
faible score de valérie pécresse à la
présidentielle encore faut-il qu
emmanuel macron et bien accepte de
donner cet espace à edouard philippe et
c'est pas gagné derrière ce manque
d'espacé il ya une stratégie du présent
la république eh bien oui au départ le
chef de l'état il voulait créer un
nouveau parti unique pour maîtriser les
petits partis satellites de sa majorité
comme horizon françois bayrou et edouard
philippe ont dit non donc cette idée est
écarté et en tout cas le but d' emmanuel
macron assez de limiter au maximum le
développement d' horizons car il estime
que son ancien pré ministre eh bien il a
une seule idée en tête c'est de viser la
présidentielle 2027 et qu'il pourrait à
faire entendre trop fortement sa voix
dans ce nouveau quinquennat emmanuel
macron il a un très mauvais souvenir un
c est la période des frondeurs qui ont
fragilisé le quinquennat de françois
hollande est d'ailleurs en janvier
dernier et bien ce chef de l'état il a
interdit aux députés du groupe agir
c'est à la droite max non compatibles à
l'assemblée nationale et notamment alors
chef franck riester il leur a interdit
de rejoindre les rangs d'horizon comme
c'était prévu le chef de l'état il est
interdit il est intervenu directement
dans ce dossier et s'est très mal passée
chez les soutiens d'edouard philippe je
n'ai vécu pas très bien parce que les
engagements de franck riester à l'époque
était d'aller vers la fusion avec avec
avec l'horizon et je rappelle que agir a
été créé en
2018 justement parce que il s'agissait
d'accompagner edouard philippe et de
préparer à dire un parti politique pour
edouard philippe donc que quelque part
le contrat moral de départ était clair
et et l'engagement lorsque a été lancé
l'idée de la fusion avec l'horizon était
claire aussi mais voilà emmanuel macron
est passée par là il a mis un petit coup
de canif dans le contrat on va finir par
une citation celle de nicolas sarkozy
qui rencontre souvent l'actuel président
et en sortant de l'elysée il dit à ses
proches je le cite l'obsession de macron
c'est edouard philippe à voir maintenant
si cette obsession va virer à la guerre
ouverte le summum ce serait d'avoir des
affrontements entre des candidats
philippe east et des candidats macro
nist dans certaines circonscriptions on
n'en est pas du tout là en tout cas bien
les deux camps ont encore jusqu'au 16
mai pour s'entendre c'est la date de fin
de dépôt des candidatures merci
alexandre pour tous ces détails
bérengère bonté rappelle que vous avez
publié une biographie d'edouard philippe
le sioux ses positions de l'archipel
pourquoi cette hostilité entre entre le
président et son ancien premier est ce
que c'est juste de la stratégie
politique ou est-ce que ça va au delà
est ce quelque chose de plus personnel
ce plan personnel il n'y a jamais rien
eu en fait où jamais rien eu de forts et
pour le coup parfois ça aide à arrondir
les angles ça n'existe pas il ya eu
pendant trois ans une façade propre
tenue pas vous souvenez pas l'épaisseur
d'une feuille de papier à cigarette donc
tout ça voilà avec le temps on a quand
même compris qu'ils avaient eu un
certain nombre de désaccords de pas que
sur la communication mais sur sur les 80
km heure sur les retraites sur le
le mode de déconfinement ya eu quand
même des nuances à la fin d'histoire
emmanuel macron
virson progrès minent son premier
ministre est là démarre une nouvelle une
nouvelle histoire c'est à dire que tu es
c'est il a gagné dans cette tente tout
ça une popularité énorme qui ne fait pas
très plaisir à emmanuel macron qui fait
craindre pas mal de choses à emmanuel
macron mai mais du coup il faut bien
gérer à la fois très populaire et et il
est vous savez loyal et libre est inné
il n'a jamais adhéré à en marche il ne
donne pas énormément de gages les
l'entourage de leurs philippe vous dis
que si si ils arrivent il a fait cette
campagne et c'est en vrai on l'a vu à la
toute fin on l'a vu à nice christian
estrosi on l'a vu à faire quelques
émissions mais il n'a pas non plus donné
énormément de gages à la macro ni et au
final moi je pense que là il est il faut
effectivement plus que chaque fois mais
ça peut se comprendre parce qu'il ya eu
zéro discussions pour l'instant de
circonscription il ya quand même un truc
un peu étrange moi je trouve à cette
façon comme s'ils s'étaient laissés
piéger tout seul ou comme si c'était
piéger tout seul c'est à dire à soutenir
d'abord et à négocier après c'est à dire
que jusqu'à la fin du second tour il a
soutenu du bout des lèvres parfois et
ces termes il a soutenu et puis tout
d'un coup il s'éteint ne pas pouvoir
négocier un peu tard en fait c'est un
peu étrange comme façon de faire
effectivement l'analyse est intéressante
nathalie secondes le on parle d épargne
et des circonscriptions etc mais le le
le c'est important point que le
président s'en occupe personnellement du
choix des députés qui vont être nommés
circonscription par circonscription
bailly déjà en 2017 il a validé toutes
les candidatures il connaît alors il y
connaît toutes les circonscriptions
extrêmement bien sur le bout des doigts
qui qui est sortant qui autrefois était
député à sous vous prenez la carte
électorale parker e-bay mémoire en plus
phénoménal donc ça aide don qui est par
ailleurs vous savez très bien on l'a
tous dit depuis cinq ans c'est lui qui
décide de tout dans cette macro nous
tout remonte à lui c'est peut-être pour
ça d'ailleurs qu'il n'a pas le temps de
ce qu'on nous dit que la jusqu'à
maintenant il s'est occupé des
législatives et que maintenant à partir
d'aujourd'hui ou de demain il va
commencer à se priver du premier
ministre vous voyez bien que tout
remonte à lui
après
j'ai oublié votre nom c'était ça s'est
elle pas à quel point il sait y rentrer
dans le temps l'accusé pétillante
vraiment pas que ça se sache c'est
alexis colère qui dit on ne va pas on
veut pas qu on ne peut pas laisser voir
les arrière cuisines parce que ça pue et
ça sort ça sent pas bon c'est pas
forcément celle alors ça sent pas le
voir sous emmanuel masse mais sortir
donc on part
les présidents mais bon je trouve que là
ils ont bien verrouiller tout ce qui se
passe au palais très honnêtement dans
les cases actuellement vers où se sont
tous qui est qu'il est qui les font
fuiter qui les instrumentalisent il faut
pas être naïf non plus en tant que
journaliste pas sûr donc c'est le
pouvoir qui à mon avis détient tous les
secrets dans les mains oui alors autres
prises de paroles importante aujourd'hui
celle
l'ancien président de la république
françois hollande il était sur france
info pour torpiller l'accord naissant
entre les filles et le parti socialiste
écoutez je trouve que cet accord ne sera
pas accepté pourquoi parce que il est
précisément il acceptable sur le camp de
ce qu'il représente électoralement la
disparition de toute candidature
socialiste dans les deux tiers ou trois
quarts des départements et deuxièmement
il met en cause des principes mêmes qui
sont les fondements de l'ensilage
devrait quoi qu'il se passe et je
souhaite que cet accord soit revu ou
repoussés de manière à ce que le parti
socialiste puisse avec ses partenaires
écologistes communistes envisager une
autre union mais quoi qu'il arrive il
faudra refonder le parti ce soit
hollande vous dit on entend encore cette
phrase il faut à refonder le parti si je
sais pas si ça veut dire encore quelque
chose benjamin morel ça veut dire
quelque chose parce que le ps a encore
des régions encore des municipalités
parfois importante est ce que ça pèse
quand même dans les négociations avec l
efi ou alors pas du tout parce que voilà
il ya une telle bérézina électorale
auprès lieu à la présidentielle que
peser parce que vous avez un ps qui est
quand même très très divisée 1 il ya une
ligne anti alliance avec life hippie
mais vous avez une ligne hollande yen
qui a toujours posé problème à la
présente direction on a un parti qui
aujourd'hui est à la fois très féodal
ise à vous parliez tout à l'heure d'un
parti très implanté dans les
collectivités territoriales le revers de
sa du coup passé que les élus locaux qui
peuvent avoir leur propre intérêt local
et bien ne sont pas toujours en ligne
avec la direction et d'un autre côté
main ce parti est aujourd'hui dans une
situation très très difficile en vue des
législatives on l'a dit mais le
financement des partis politiques il est
dit au résultat que vous faites aux
législatives et vous devez faire plus
d'un pour cent dans 50 circonscriptions
et ensuite c'est payé à la voix et même
si vous avez un groupe politique
derrière l'argent qui est mis sur le
groupe politique n'existe que si jamais
vous avez la première partie du
financement c'est-à-dire les 1% dans 50
circonscriptions donc les le parti
socialiste qui aujourd'hui comme élevé
est dans une situation financière quand
même pas tout à fait enviable est dans
une situation difficile par ailleurs le
ps voudrait maintenant un groupe or il
faut bien comprendre que aux
législatives l'une des règles de base
pour comprendre cette élection c'est que
c'est une élection qui profite aux
alliances électorales plus votre camp
est une île que vous avez une chance
d'atteindre le second tour si jamais
votre camp est divisé et bien il ya
toutes les chances comme à une
présidentielle en réalité sauf périodes
de triangulaires mais si on part sur une
abstention 50% il y aura très peu de
triangulaires et donc à partir de là il
faut arriver à unifier votre camp
aujourd'hui le camp de la gauche il ne
signifie pas sans un défi et si vous
n'avez pas et les filles vous avez
toutes les chances possibles pour que la
plupart des second tour des législatives
se fasse entre la reine qui tient son
électorat électorat mobilisables
électorat qui sera là masqués lectorat
plutôt centriste dont les
caractéristiques sociologiques le
conduisent à se mobiliser et de l'autre
côté la droite voire l'extrême droite
donc pour le ps même c'est l'alliance de
la carpe et du lapin et bien malgré tout
il faut y aller c'est un gros plan sur
le vote rural que je vous propose
maintenant si dans les grandes villes et
mâcon s'est largement l'a largement
emporté par dont marine le pen est
arrivé en tête dans les petites communes
un exemple dont les dans la sarthe on
est à ecommoy ou la candidate du
rassemblement national obtenu 51% des
suffrages exprimés reportage signé ccid
fiction
il y a cinq ans les habitants des com -
avaient voté à 55% pour emmanuel macron
cette fois marine le pen est arrivé en
tête avec près de 52 % des voix sur le
marché ces résultats n'étonnent pas les
habitants beaucoup se sont sentis
oubliés lors du dernier quinquennat on
s'en fout
d'ailleurs ya peu il n'y a plus de
commerces pratiquement tous ces partis
dans les petits villages par trous aux
alentours et j'ai pas dû aider des gens
qui sont dans le besoin
kapitalis ils sont de l'argent de plus
en plus ses habitants voter pour
exprimer leur mécontentement
déçu par trop de promesses politiques
non tenues ils n'attendent plus rien du
président élu vous promet peut-être que
le gasoil ils devaient baisser
apparemment il va remonter au bout de
dix-quinze tant au niveau des retraites
on nous promettait que ça serait
peut-être éventuellement 64 ça va être
venu à 65 ans ça va passer d'office
enfin c'est déjà de choses comme ça on
nous promet avant puis maintenant depuis
qu'on est élu on ne fait plus rien ils
disent qu'ils veulent un j'ai aucune
confiance en ses en ces hommes là voilà
ils font ce qu'ils veulent avec les
chiffres font ce qu'ils veulent avec
tout et ils ont le pouvoir surtout donc
clairement voilà c'est pas on peut pas
faim je peux pas avoir confiance dans
ces choses là d'autres espèrent qu
emmanuel macron remettre des services
publics au coeur de ces communes rurales
pro n'a plus de perception la poste elle
est partie
même partir peut-être tout ça c'est
primordial tout ça dans les dents la
ruralité voilà et c'est pas s'est occupé
de la ruralité se trouve
j'ai sûr que non nous ce soir de
plusieurs jours oui
malgré tout les toutes les promesses à
mêler bouge pas sur grand choix la faune
le maire de la commune le vote du second
tour à ecommoy reflète une tendance des
petits villages de la sarthe on atteint
des scores à 68% 69% 70% avec commune à
à 15 kilomètres d'ici
oui c'est assez étonnant étonnant car
ces communes situées à 30 minutes du
mans ne sont ni isolé ni sinistré
économiquement et encore moins
confrontés aux problématiques liées à
l'immigration pour lui cette poussée du
vote et rennes est liée aux réseaux
sociaux caisse de résonance des
problématiques de la ville le rôle des
réseaux sociaux
rapproche considérablement
les problèmes qui sont vécues dans les
villes des gens qui sont la campagne ça
crée une peur ça crée une peur que qui
ne viennent pas chez nous se greffer des
problèmes qui a dans les villes un
sentiment de peur plus qu'une réalité
pour le maire d'ecommoy pour gagner
l'électorat de ces communes rurales
emmanuel macron va devoir se pencher sur
les réclamations de ses habitants lors
des cinq prochaines années ce qui est
intéressant dans ce reportage plus
globalement l'analyse des chiffres de
dimanche nathalie seconde c'est que
cette cet ancrage local du rassemblement
national ils se renforcent élections
grande élection après grandes élections
on va dire ça comme ça et notamment
présidentielle après présidentielle
marine le pen là quand alors les
projections sur les législatives elle
peut-être pas dire grands médias comme
je vois je vous dois aussi la tête
jamais mal d'une centaine de députés
potentiel pour le rassemblement national
non et je sais pas du tout moi ce que je
dis c'est que oui ils ont quand même ils
ont quand même du mal c'est un électorat
qui s'abstient beaucoup plus que par
exemple électorat d'emmanuel macron et
ensuite
ils ont du mal à trouver des
représentants failli on l'a vu aux
dernières législatives en 2017 il avait
du mal à trouver même des candidats même
dans des endroits où ils ont beaucoup
d'électeurs donc je crois pas tellement
moi j'entends plutôt parler d'un groupe
et rennes à 20 entre 20 et 30 députés
ils ont un groupe oui mais s'ils
s'étaient c'était un sondage harris
interactive pour challenge qui aura
montré une seule fois parce qu'on a
décidé d'être prudent et pas
feuilletonner toute la semaine avec
cette seule projection proposée vers les
législatives mais là on était oui en
soit avec ou sans alliance on était
autour d'une centaine de des publics aux
dernières législatives
le rn à 7 députés pour arriver à
emporter législatives il ya trois
conditions qui sont pas remplies d'abord
l'électorat n'est pas mobiliser un
électorat qui s'abstient en règle
générale hommes résidentiel peut-être se
mobilisera t-il mais quand bien même
ensuite faut avoir un système doit
changer dès le soir de la présidentielle
enfin l'attitude
de marine le pen ou de jean luc
mélenchon au soir du 2 oui l'ont entouré
pas du tout la même qui a 5 ans donc il
ya peut-être une mobilisation officielle
de leur électorat comme un électorat
l'électorat mélenchonistes est
paradoxalement plus mobilisables à ça va
être relativement compliquée à voir ça
peu mais quand bien même le deuxième
élément c'est qu'il faut être pris dans
un système d'alliances on l'évoqué tout
à l'heure ils vont atteindre le second
tour là les situer la situation avec
eric zemmour n'êtes pas et par ailleurs
l'électorat lr compatibles il va y avoir
des candidats aient l'air donc ça va
être très compliqué d'atteindre ne
serait-ce que le second tour vous
atteignez le second tour le mode de
scrutin a été fait pour les partis
centristes le centre se retrouve face à
la droite la gauche votent pour lui et
vice versa quand vous êtes le rn quoi
qu'il arrive tout le monde virtuel et
donc à partir de là vous êtes
structurellement sous représentés à part
lorsqu'il ya eu la proportionnelle 1986
le rn enfin le fn à l'époque n'a jamais
eu groupe parlementaire c'est
intéressant mélange avant parce que
jusqu'à présent
le rassemblement national snob eric
zemmour ils partirent conquête alors
qu'on pourrait se dire fort de cette
analyse qu'il va en avoir besoin malgré
tout
cela les projections si si on avez
avec la valeur qu'elles peuvent avoir
mais
dresse un tableau qui consisterait à
imaginer à avoir brisé -7% et avec les
héros et lui en vérité le risque pour
marine le pen il est
enfin on peut comprendre quelles
qu'elles qu'elles ignorent cette cet
électorat là je veux dire c'est au
lecteur à non mais je veux dire c'est
eric zemmour n'est finalement pas du
tout là où ils pensaient être et au
final sont les sources et législatives
ça va se terminer roland avec avec zéro
éduquer les le quel est le risque
qu'elle prend sincèrement
ça change pas du tout la donne si elle
s'allie avec les candidats reconquête
soir elle gagnera 5 députés mais elle
entretiendra grâce à elle un parti et un
candidat qui ont créé un objectif
prendre sa place en 2027 et avec des
financements qui par ailleurs lui
permettront d'avoir les reins solides
pendant cinq ans donc entre cinq députés
et entretenir un rival qui n'a qu'une
envie c'est 12 évincé direct le choix
paraît assez évident vu les divergences
et je peux je pose une question quand
même pas ce que je vais vous dire ce que
vous me disiez à nathalie secondes et
qui est tout à fait juste je me rappelle
que pour je crois que c'était l'élection
les élections municipales le rn avait
proposé aux femmes de garder leur nom de
jeune fille rappelez-vous pour ne pas
être justement identifiable facilement
par les lecteurs pourquoi parce qu'il y
avait quand même un plafond de verre
abri et il me semble que vous avez
raison la projection de censier je sais
pas sur quoi elle se base mais il
faudrait avoir un nombre de personnes à
présenter quoi des personnes des plus
table je peux dire est en tout cas je
crois que le rm manque absolument de
forçat ils n'ont pas les forces vives
donc ce sera déjà le premier le premier
handicap pour lui
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat je rappelle le
titre de votre
yves bérengère bonté le sioux
portrait biographie d'edouard philippe
publié aux éditions de l'archipel